there's a lot of setup here especially
by individuals like bill gates that
wasn't just funneling money into the
mainstream media because he gave he gave
hundreds of billions of dollars to the
mainstream media that buys a lot of
influence he they're smart people who
know what's going on i just i'm sorry i
mean if we could it's so annoying to do
the cliche bill gates no no no it's
important to mention here because this
is a man that has far more influence
than we even know about and we already
know hundreds of millions of dollars to
the mainstream media and you report just
give me some evidence other than the guy
says stupid things to the press
he doesn't say stupid things to the
press he buys off the press he gave them
319 million dollars to media outlets
like cnn nbc npr the atlantic the bbc
the guardian all are on his payroll all
are on his paycheck what does that mean
talk about the way that he positions
himself in society especially what does
it mean what does that mean things like
the vaccine industry
explain to me beyond i saw a guy do a
bunch of things that make me question
him look i don't like the guy i think
he's got weird weird views on the world
i don't trust him i think he's a bad
person i look at his history and how he
started my uh microsoft and how he he
moved through silicon valley much like
steve jobs also not a good guy but the
problem i have with this like here's a
guy who did a thing it's like yo what's
happening in the world right now
involves thousands of people we can talk
about donald trump's role in 15 days to
slow the spread but i don't think trump
was a big player and exactly what was
going on i think he got swept up in it
we could talk about joe biden's attempt
at a vaccine minute we could struck down
and then everyone's like but but but you
know bill gates but biden's not there
biden is not a human being who's pa
who's not even consciously there there's
other people behind him there's special
interest behind them there's major
corporations
there's globally we can talk about how
pfizer
has been dumping money into these these
companies uh into the media outlets
sponsored by sponsored by getting
getting no why not ability contracts why
shouldn't we talk about them they're
hugely influenced players the issues and
there's players is
they've always done this the koch
brothers are doing this and george soros
is doing that they are bill gates is
doing this
you want me to give you a list of the 2
000 billionaires who are all doing this
look i get it it's frustrating for me
because people talk about bill gates in
some superficial manner like did you
know that he gave money to the media
what does that mean tell me what that
means i know he owns influence the dude
has had influence for decades they all
do this one story does not say anything
about the fact that
one story after another story after
another story
literally trying to control the weather
it's his obsession he i'm not he's he's
making gmo mosquitoes if you think this
person no i'm not yes you are no i'm not
absolutely not you can name george you
can name george soros and the da's he's
been funding this is why we're
frustrated and why shouldn't you
what frustrates frustrates me here is
you get a story from june 2021 where uh
barda which is a bio research lab in the
u.s i believe through hhs gets a
weaponized smallpox drug uh approved i
believe was a proof i could be wrong
about this
bill gates comes out and says i'm
worried about weaponized smallpox and
all of a sudden the conspiracy realm
lights up saying bill gates is doing
whatever and it's like dude he read the
news that's not what we said i never
said anything about you you did i'm
saying the issue i take is yeah there's
other people that take it too far of
course and so the issue i take is like
i've just had so many conversations
about the obsession over bill gates yeah
i think it's a it's a red herring to go
after the individuals because like if
you have a corrupt king that's
terrorizing his subjects you want to
remove that king you're going to get
another king and he may or may not
terrorize what you want to do is disrupt
the monarchy and change the system so
that there is no possibility for it you
need to replace the puppet so the
puppets look all the way because it's
different
in the blue puppet yeah avoid that and
no no no no i want to get this puppet
you want to fix the system so that one
guy can't become a
right trillionaire listen maybe here's
the problem
right now we have a culture and culture
is more powerful than politics and law
as i've mentioned numerous times the
easiest way to explain it is there's
wacky laws in massachusetts you know
they have a law from the 1600s you can't
put a pie in your window sill on sunday
afternoon because it attracts bears and
now no cop will enforce that
so when you get
a hundred million people and you're
standing before them and they say tell
us what's happening you say this bill
gates guy spent money in the press they
go what am i supposed to do with it i
wouldn't say that no stop or you say do
not let the government put their boot on
your neck do not let them mandate
medical procedures influence the culture
i have never never
i i don't like i don't like doing these
bits where it's like did you know person
x did x there or did y you have all of
these youtubers who make videos about
people people people people people
people and then regular people who are
standing at ready saying i want the
world to be a better place for my kids i
want to make sure i have my freedoms and
my liberties what should i do you should
be met at bill gates and they go okay i
won't fight in any meaningful way for
principles i won't focus on on what's
happening in my community i won't vote
locally i'll complain about bill gates
then those people go out to rallies and
they hold a big sign saying bill gates
and then when regular people show up to
go look at the crazy people look at the
crazy people no so this is what
frustrates me whenever it comes to the
vaccine stuff everyone's like let's have
a debate over science and we're not
scientists and i'm like why why when we
can just say we are advocates for
freedom we are american citizens who
know the history of this country and the
founding fathers who said we demand
freedom and respect and tell the people
instead of trying to pretend to be a
scientist who's going to argue about
medical efficacy we can just say i
reject your attempts to mandate a
medical procedure on me the two are not
exclusive you could have both and i
don't just obsessively talk about bill
gates i talk about him i talk about all
the other very influential people who
are doing that but i also talk about
solutions i also talk about personal
responsibility i also talk about the
need for you to wake up from this
trauma-based mind control and psychosis
that people are going through by
watching the mainstream media by
watching what bill gates funds by
watching what all these other
individuals nobody in order to trick you
and lie nobody knows i disagree with you
i absolutely listen to the world no i
don't think i do because if people
actually do find out the reality of the
true existence of this world which many
of them are right now many people are
waking up when people
see the true reality of it they start
understanding the players behind the
scenes here then they could start
implementing policies where they're not
victimized by these players and their
games that they play on the rest of the
population we don't get towards a
convention of states assuming that's
what we want we don't get towards a
populist uprising because a bunch of
people went outside complaining about
bill gates i'm not saying complaining
about bill gates i'm saying understand
the problem and be able to
diagnose it correctly without playing
their games of here's a puppet vote for
this puppet this puppet's
george soros is the guy funding the das
yeah we do we are not seeing parents
rise up and revolt because they found
out about bill gates we're seeing we're
seeing their children and their families
being affected they're seeing their
culture be destroyed and it's it's and
who's so common who's doing that who's
responsible for for all who's doing all
this bad stuff it doesn't
matter it does i think it's a result of
the system if you have a technocracy
removing one technocrat another one will
fill the void so we want to figure out a
system that's a politician ian same with
not attacking same with their politics
you remember not present on upper
echelons because there is an inner
circle that inner circle deserves to be
addressed we have different approaches i
think it's important along with going
after the solutions along with
understanding the full problem that
we're seeing in front of us to be able
to fully just to be able to fully deal
with this problem you got to fully
understand it and you can't just be
looking at the consequences you can't
just be going after the side effects
okay and the challenge we have is that
none of this is relevant because what
matters is culture culture building
politics is down downstream from culture
and a bunch of people who have said i've
identified a source of the problem and i
believe it's bill gates are gonna are
going to convince no one and change
nothing the truth but you know what but
you know what people want a symbol for
their oppression so they isolate
an individual for a long time it was
george soros and still is now bill gates
is filling that role every single story
every quote every comment has brought up
and i'm just wondering like are we
having a debate about this one guy we
don't like are we going to talk about
how we're going to influence the culture
so that these la these laws can't the
culture is downstream from the
technology that's basically functioning
as a gatekeeping system allowing what
culture is seen where and then you got
to say who built that centralized
technology and bill did build some of it
but
a lot of people have built a lot of
central and are in the process of
building centralized uh tech technology
system i think allison mcdowell is
really a fascinating human being i was
well i would love to know
so like some of these solutions like i
agree with what you're saying when we
especially when we point at certain
people i want to know like what is the
actionable step so when you're talking
about solutions
i would love to hear some of what you
think would actually be solutions for
people in mass families your or whatever
like at home in the home solutions and
do any of them have to do with dmt yeah
dft is a personal decision that
individuals should do their own research
their own homework we're all live
and it's yes of course so we all we all
go through it when we dream every single
night that's something that should be up
to the individual
but but again i think understanding
exactly what's going on is the first
step towards dealing with the problem
obviously we have a very sick society
obviously we have a very corrupted
society understanding how it's corrupted
who it's corrupted by and how we cannot
be corrupted by it i think is the first
step whether it's
you know the school the indoctrination
centers whether it's the medical centers
that keep charging people 30 for an
aspirin that rob people of their wealth
and health whether it's the banking
system whether it's all the systems that
are thrown and shoved down our throats
every single day that are scams ponzi
schemes against the american people we
when we are victims to it when we are
blind to it we give all of our power to
these individuals and i'm saying these
individuals are doing all this i think
that's an essential part to break it all
down and to say hey you know what maybe
i won't vote with my dollar at this
particular business maybe i won't put my
child in an indoctrination center maybe
i will look into homeschooling maybe i
won't depend on all my food from you
know the the amazon or a walmart maybe
i'll start looking into farming maybe
i'll start building a community of
people that i could actually have a
support system around me and i think
just acknowledging like hey there's some
big bad people out there some of them
are sociopaths understanding that
reality and not blaming everything on on
generalized topics like culture culture
is absolutely important but you build
that culture from a sense of reality not
from a sense of i just want this let me
go get this this is why
you know the freedom
look this
i used to work for a bunch of nonprofits
i used to fundraise for green priests
about for a month and a half i worked
for a couple a couple really big
national non-profits
and i was a nation's best fundraiser i
was able to walk up to a random person
on the street make them hand over their
credit card to me in 30 seconds this is
what the job is you've seen them on the
street they say hey come over here and
talk to me and i will tell you the one
thing that never convinces anybody is
blaming a person they don't know they're
confused by it how does that affect me
who is this guy what does he do what
does this mean bill gates has has bought
me in influence in the media he's
manipulative he has these weird ideas
and he's not a doctor and they say
that's weird what is it how does how
does what does he do i don't understand
in order to give someone enough
information to understand why bill gates
is a bad person and why george soros is
a bad person and why these other
billionaires because there are many and
many many of them is a bad person you'd
have to put them in a school for years
to really break down all this stuff
and so what you end up having is you
have a bunch of people who've been in
this world for a really really long time
they know and they can easily recall the
history of the you know how microsoft
came to be how they got their first
deals they went and they bought it the
arguments between steve jobs and bill
gates steve jobs the things he did they
were very very just dirty individuals
and i mean like like
just willing to exploit and rip off and
and corrupt and we know these things
but then there's a guy's a truck driver
and you go to him and you say all of
your problems stem from
bill gates is a billionaire who does
these things and he's going to be like
look guy i have no idea how that's going
to give me any information i need to get
my kids food but then we can bring it
back to their world we can speak to them
on their terms and things they
understand and say
hey
should you be forced to do x y or z by
your government and they'll say no it's
like this is the opening of the door
you say the things that directly affect
you that are causing you problems can be
solved if you wake up and start paying
attention but what we get a lot of is
george soros the left has their koch
brothers the left has their mercers and
i've been in these activist groups and
i've seen just how ineffective it is to
to say a word that means nothing to
somebody a name that means nothing to
somebody but think you're you're giving
some great revelation joe rogan just
pointed out to alex jones when he was on
the show on tuesday that alex has the
problem of knowing and so when he tries
explaining to people and he says really
like things that are so out there they
don't understand it actually makes them
push away from you you cannot walk up to
a person who's never experienced and who
doesn't understand the nitty-gritty of
what's going on immediately jump crank
up the dial to 11 and think they'll
listen to you we're not doing that we're
not jumping up to random people we're
having a talk show where we delve deep
into
complicated topics the reason people
listen to us is because it's an honest
real conversation that isn't afraid just
to be on the surface level we go deep
down and i think this is why this
podcast is so special because we could
do that and i disagree with your
characterization we're not talking to
random people on the street here we're
talking to an informed public that is
paying attention and i don't think
everything that happens in this world is
a coincidence i do think there's bad
people out there i do believe there is
going to to be really bad things that
are going to continue to continue to
happen unless people realize that these
people are actually doing it and i think
that's also a part of the solution as
well as taking personal responsibility
for yourself as a human being and that's
something i preached from the very
beginning be informed what's going on
don't be a victim of these people move
away from them and support systems and
structures and businesses that align
with your principles with your morality
and what you believe deep down in
yourself
when i think of like this whole system
and like how we fix i think of it kind
of a game theory and military theory i
think of like band of brothers taking a
bunker when you have a target or when
you're focusing on like who did that
like let's say you're talking about bill
gates or whatever you don't want to like
yell out hey bill and like go directly
at him because that's then you become an
easy target you kind of want to to flank
the the target and like
confuse the target and like
i really and ultimately persuade that i
mean ultimately we're not at war with
each other we're we're on the same team
trying to help society we just have
different methods so you want to kind of
convince the target and
i i think what luke is doing is looking
through a telescope backwards because
when you start with the people and not
with the ideas people don't understand
what you're trying to say when you tell
them when you come up when you tell
people about this idea and you say
something like and i really think that
bill gates is a symptom of this they may
understand it better because that idea
affects them directly centralization
affects people who drive trucks it
affects people who work at small
businesses and this is something that
they will understand much better than
saying george soros is our enemy it
doesn't matter what george soros is
doing doing i'm just trying to drive a
truck and keep my family people want a
symbol
of of something that they they want a
symbol to represent what they believe
oppresses them or causes them problems
and harm
and for a lot of people it's very easy
to just name a person
the thing about bill gates he's a bad
guy he's a pretty pretty bad guy he does
a lot of bad things a lot of bad ideas
he's in my opinion a sociopath
but we're not talking about the other
thousand billionaires that do the exact
same thing
and this is the issue i take with it it
would be impossible for us to actually
go through the huge list of all of these
powerful global elites of old money and
new money of arrogance and ego
of um ill repute people who who are
callous utilitarians who believe in that
some some people can be sacrificed who
are willing to commit atrocities people
like fauci for instance i mean this guy
is is dark the the stuff he's been
funding the lies he said these are
people who just don't care and there are
so many of them
but it can but it can change
if people are told very simply like
simple ways to improve their lives to
give them information about basic things
that are going on and you open the door
and allow them to walk through it you
don't run up to them jump drop kick them
and smash them through the window and
try and push them outside because
they'll freak out so when it comes to
you know like promoting a cause and
trying to convince people to say sign up
for a non-profit become a member or
something they've never heard of
the one thing i would always do when it
came to you know how do i convince
someone to want to save the forest you
have to make it relatable and start with
something they understand because in my
opinion it's disrespectful to demand
someone know something they've never
heard of
so if you if you approach it with
here's the guy here's the bad guy he's
the villain and then people like i said
go out with signs saying the villain
everyone else looks at that and says
that is meaningless i disagree with your
characterizations with linda and yours
as well because
i think saying hey don't talk about this
don't talk about this isn't going to
help anything in the long run and if
you've looked at what i've been talking
about for a very long time if you want
to look for the person that's
responsible for are your woes for all
your problems you have to look in the
mirror and once you look in the mirror
you start understanding the personal
responsibility that you have within
yourself to understand what's going on
and not fall for the traps thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time